good morning the Norwegian Nobel
Committee has decided to award the Nobel
Peace Prize for 2016 to Colombian
President Juan Manuel Santos for his
resolute efforts to bring the country's
more than 50 year long civil war to an
end a word that had costs has cost the
life of at the lives of at least 220,000
Colombians and displaced close to 6
million people the award should also be
seen as a tribute to the Colombian
people who despite great hardships and
abuses have not given up hope of just
peace and to all the parties who have
contributed to this peace process this
tribute is paid not least to the
representatives of the countless victims
of the civil war President Santos
initiated the negotiations that
culminated in the peace accord between
the Colombian government and the FARC
guerrillas and he has consistently
sought to move the peace process forward
well knowing that the Accord was
controversial he was instrumental in
ensuring that Colombian voters were able
to voice their opinion concerning the
Accord in a referendum the outcome of
the vote was not what President Santos
wanted a narrow majority of the over 13
million Colombians who cast their
ballots said no to the Accord this
result has created great uncertainty
as to the future of Colombia there is a
real danger that the peace process will
come to a halt and that civil war will
flare up again this makes it even more
important that the parties headed by
President Santos and FARC guerrilla
leader
Rodrigo londoño continue to respect the
ceasefire the fact that the majority of
the voters said no to the peace accord
does not necessarily mean that the peace
process is dead the referendum was not a
vote for or against peace the referendum
was the no side what the no side
rejected was not the desire for peace
but a specific peace agreement the
Norwegian Nobel Committee emphasizes the
importance of the fact that president
Santos is now inviting all parties to
participate in a broad-based national
dialogue aimed at advancing the peace
process
even those who opposed the peace accord
have welcomed such a dialogue the Nobel
Committee hopes that all parties will
take their share of responsibility and
participate constructively in the
upcoming peace talks striking a balance
between the need for national
reconciliation and ensuring justice for
the victims will be a particularly
difficult challenge there are no simple
answers as to how this should be
accomplished an important feature of the
Colombian peace process so far has been
the participation of
to sensitives of the civil war victims
witnessing the courage and will of the
victims representatives to testify about
atrocities and to confront the
perpetrators from every side of the
conflict has made a profound impression
by awarding this year's Peace Prize to
President Juan Manuel Santos the
Norwegian Nobel Committee wishes to
encourage all those who are striving to
achieve peace reconciliation and justice
in Colombia the President himself has
made it clear that he will continue to
work for peace right up until the very
last day in office the committee hopes
that the Peace Prize will give him
strength to succeed in this demanding
task furthermore it is the committee's
hope that in the years to come the
Colombian people will reap the fruits of
the ongoing peace and reconciliation
process only then will the country be
able to address effectively major
challenges such as poverty social
injustice and drug-related crime the
civil war in Colombia is one of the
longest civil wars in modern times and
the sole remaining armed conflict in the
Americas it is the Norwegian Nobel
committees firm belief that President
Santos despite the majority vote in the
referendum has brought the bloody
conflict significantly closer to a
peaceful solution and that much of the
groundwork has been led for both the
verifiable this
of the FARC guerrillas and a historic
process of national fraternity and
reconciliation his endeavors to promote
peace thus fulfill the criteria and
spirit of Alfred Nobel's
will this year's price
first of all encourages a process more
than a result due to the fact as you say
that the slim majority of Colombians
they voted no in the referendum it is an
acknowledgement of the very hard work
and the very important initiative that
President Santos has made and it is of
course and as we state in the
announcement texts a strong
encouragement we hope for all parties in
this negotiating processes to do their
utmost to reach a good result acceptable
to the people why have you chosen not to
divide the price between the parties of
the peace process
there are many parties in this peace
process and the announcement text I just
read to you shows very clearly that's
the president Santos has been taking the
very first and historic initiative there
has been other tries to reach peace
deals in Colombia but this time he went
that they put it all in and the
government he as the leader of the
government went all in with a strong
will to reach a result and this is why
we have put the emphasis on the
President of Colombia but remember he is
also the head of state of Colombia would
it also be nearly impossible to give the
award to a guerrilla movement we never
comment on
those who do not receive the rewards we
concentrate our comments on the laureate
of this year have any of you spoken to
the president yet and what was his
reaction no we have not done that in the
modern world it's a bit tricky to try to
announce in advance but we are trying to
establish contacts right no do you think
he will be as surprised as the rest of
us we will see what will be the comments
of the president do you think this price
will be disputed worldwide well it's not
uh normal for a Peace Prizes to the
Nobel Peace Prize to be disputed that is
not our aim our aim is to honor the work
that has been done to honor also all the
parties in the conflict and to tell to
the Colombian people that we encourage
you to go on through all the parties who
have participated in this process you
explicitly said it was an encouragement
but I wonder whether you fear it might
act the other way for the parties who
might feel like on the other side of the
divide
they might deserve you as well I do not
think so there are strong reasons as I
say in the announcement texts to put a
light on the president himself his role
as president and as in a way the the
keeper of a process is very very
important especially these days when
there is a risk of the process stopping
there has been a referendum in Colombia
and the people has said no to this
particular peace treaty isn't that a
little disrespectful of the democracy of
Colombia that you know gives a peace
price to the president no on the
contrary
we clearly show that we of course
respect a democratic process and the
democratic both of the Colombian people
but the people of Colombia did not say
no to peace as you stated yourself they
said no to this particular agreement and
there is no a process of opening of
dialogue also with all the other parties
in the Colombian society and to try to
move the process forward this is
extremely important to avoid that the
civil war flares up again yes it's a
Norwegian news agency this year you had
a record number of candidates was it
hard for the committee to reach this
decision did you have a lot of
controversy among yourselves it was not
harder than it used to be even though we
had more candidates this year a lot of
good candidates but we never comment on
the other candidates we have a process
that goes on every year in the same way
and we have very good discussions around
the table in the committee room behind
me so it has not been harder than a
normal process notice are you hoping
that this price will restart or save the
peace process in Colombia we hope it
will encourage all good initiatives and
all the parties who could make a
difference in a peace process and give
Colombia finally a piece after decades
war okay and one more question did you
consider including the leader in in
the price
we will never comment on other
candidates and other possibilities our
decision is the one you have in front of
you
in the announcement text but we have
followed of course the development in
Colombia over a long time very very
closely
okay
okay doesn't seem to be any questions
[Music]